i feel like i'm just falling apart
this is so embarrassing
i am
how am i ever going to get out of this i
can't get a grip
[Music]
so
it's never easy to admit when you feel
like you're failing at something
especially when you're like a
perfectionist like me and i think when a
lot of us like watch these journeys on
instagram or youtube
we expect to see
a very familiar pattern we want to see
the problem we want to see that there's
some kind of solution or journey that
we're going through to fix the problem
and then there's the happily ever after
and like i i guess i i got that i showed
that with my ivf journey with my eating
disorder after the fact but
that is just not
how
the cards are stacked for this so i want
to catch you guys up to speed and be
absolutely honest and transparent with
you because there's a lot here to unpack
this is hard but first let me tell you
about my sponsor open farm so as a mom
and dietitian i take feeding my babies
nutritious meals pretty seriously and
while my kids may be a little more
demanding i put the same consideration
into my fur baby poppy's meals as well
so poppy's a double doodle and like her
mama the girl likes to eat so she was
very excited when i brought home open
farm food i love that they use human
grade meat as the first ingredients
rather than meat meal and it's packed
with fruits and vegetables so it's not
surprising that poppy loves the taste i
mean the dog gets her fair share of
toddler handouts so she's already got
quite the palette for the good stuff all
of their ingredients are ethically
sourced so for example the pork is
raised in a cage-free environment and
the beef is grass-fed right now poppy's
getting open farms ethically raised poor
kibble twice a day and she goes crazy
when i add in some of their grass-fed
beef bone broth on top just for some
extra flavor i also usually add a few
dog friendly fruits and vegetables on
there as well for extra antioxidants she
also gets a few treats in the day for
not barking or not jumping up but it's
been a huge relief to find a pet food
that poppy's not only so excited about
eating but that i also know will help
keep her healthy and happy for years to
come so if you want to check out open
farm for your favorite furry friends
check out my link in the description and
use my promo code abby to get 15 off of
your order and i just want to pop in
here with my general disclaimer i am not
a doctor i'm not a psychologist or a
psychiatrist this protocol is just what
my doctor has recommended explicitly for
me so this video should in no way be
taken as a prescription or promotion of
any kind of pharmaceutical protocol if
anything this video should serve as a
call to action to reduce the stigma
around mental illness and getting help
for your mental illness so if you are
struggling with anxiety depression or
other mental illnesses please reach out
to a qualified mental health
professional to get the help that you
need also if you guys are new here don't
forget to subscribe to this channel ring
that bell so you never miss out and
follow me over on tick tock and
instagram abby's kitchen now back to
your regularly scheduled program
just feels like it's all going
so
until i catch you up i just finished my
herbal
antimicrobials to really to
tackle the hydrogen bacteria overgrowth
that i had
after i eradicated the methane dominant
bacteria and i was feeling like really
good i was happy my bowel movements were
good my bloating was low it was all
looking pretty good so i went on a
little family vacation for march break
with um
my kids in florida and i mean like
travel with kids is always stressful
don't like don't get me wrong i love it
i love to spend that time undivided time
with the kids but it's stressful you
know you're in a different place i'm
staying with family
it's a lot at least for me and i feel
like that's often like a bit of a
disruption to
some of my comfortable routines and with
eating specifically you know eating for
sibo or whatever it means i have to be
like more flexible to just accommodate
everyone else so like i'm eating more
restaurant foods i feel like i ate a
pretty like gut friendly diet while i
was in florida um but i would say i had
like more salad than i do at home
because normally i have most of my
vegetables cooked in like soup it was
like just too hot there to have soup i
wasn't gonna order soup every day i had
gazpacho maybe twice
probably not the most
sibo friendly dish because of the raw
garlic raw onions and i would say that
sometimes i would have to like have like
a mini meal because if everyone was
going out for brunch or for breakfast or
for lunch i maybe wasn't super hungry so
i would have like a mini meal and then a
bigger meal later also not ideal when it
comes to meal spacing it wasn't perfect
by any means but i did the best that i
could and i kept it with my supplements
and my bowel movements were actually
pretty good and normal while i was away
so that was like the food and digestion
piece in florida insomnia wise i also
slept pretty well in florida which is
actually really surprising to me because
i normally do not um but twice while i
was in florida i don't know like maybe i
just was eating intuitively and it was
hot that day and i didn't feel like a
really big heavy meal for dinner and i
probably had something lighter than
usual and i woke up in the middle of the
night to pee as i normally do and i felt
hungry so i went and got a snack but it
wasn't just like have a snack and go to
bed feel good it was like i had a snack
and i had to go to bed and i still was
hungry so i'd have like another snack
and this probably would happen like
three times before i could quell the
hunger and actually get back to sleep so
seems like a totally normal thing and
not a big deal but this is really the
difference between a normal healthy mind
and a mind with an anxiety disorder
because this is really like how we have
a recipe here for like a perfect anxiety
insomnia ibs
store so long story short the day we
traveled home my normal bathroom routine
got like thrown off and i know it's
super normal and super common for like
travel days or like traveling in general
to just like mess up our digestion or
our usual kind of bathroom routine so i
don't know if you guys experience that
yourself like leave me a note below
we're all in this together but again
normally i can kind of like get back on
track the next day but this time i
didn't i was so anxious about not
pooping basically before i got on the
plane it became a self-fulfilling
prophecy i got super uncomfortable very
bloated very gassy super constipated all
week long and i still have not gotten
back to my kind of florida or pre-travel
poops if that makes sense and again this
to most people would be like not a big
deal but for me
with my history of my sibo and
everything i've gone through to get to
this point i am terrified like in the
middle of the night i'd be laying in bed
feeling uncomfortably constipated like i
really just want to go but i can't
because of my anxiety
and this overwhelming fear that the
sibo's coming back and i'm never going
to get it under control and it is like
debilitating the fear alone is
debilitating and that is not even like
the whole story here that's the sibo bit
so like shelf that for like a hot minute
i had a whole other weird problem that i
was concurrently dealing with basically
when i got home i found myself waking up
in the middle of the night hungry like
i'd get up to pee and immediately i'd
think i'm hungry and no amount of food
could quell my hunger like i'm gonna
talk numbers for a second so please
trigger warning if this is too much for
you but i would eat a whole
normal day of food maybe like 2 000
calories of food totally normal for me
i'd get to after dinner time and i would
have like a 500 calorie snack just as
assurance that i wouldn't wake up hungry
and then i'd wake up anyways and as soon
as i would be up my mind the first
thought in my mind was i'm gonna get
hungry and obviously it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy because the
mind and the gut are so intimately
connected that i would feel hungry and
i'd have to go downstairs to have a
snack so i'd go down and have a snack
which would wake me up more it would
just interfere with my ability to get
back to sleep more i'd have a snack i'd
go back upstairs and feel full i'd lay
in bed bam i'm hungry i'm still hungry i
go back downstairs have it on the snack
it would go on and on and on there was
one night that i was up from 11 p.m
because i woke up to pee and i felt
hungry and i had like two pears and i
think like five pieces of peanut butter
toast that's how much i needed to eat
and i still went back to bed and i was
up the whole night feeling hungry and
this is not like a typical binge there
was nothing about this that was like oh
i'm gonna sneak down to the kitchen and
have a slice of cake when nobody's
watching no this was like oh my gosh
please can i just make this
physiological feeling of hunger this
ravenous eating at my stomach hunger go
away so i can go back to
sleep that was what i was experiencing
it was bizarre and a lot of you guys
might be thinking like well abby
intuitive eating would say you should
eat and yes if we were to look at only
one principle of intuitive eating honor
your hunger that would be true but when
you're dealing also with an anxiety
disorder like it's not the whole picture
it's not the whole story it's so
complicated especially when it comes to
dealing with the intersection between
the brain and the gut so you know i've
talked to my therapist about issues like
this in the past um and often she has
said that i have some kind of ocd like
tendencies and i know that like they've
come out in the past with my eating
disorder and they've come out with my in
my sleep often all of these issues have
kind of compulsive or obsessive natures
to them and in the past with my sleep i
would often like create this crutch this
habit with my sleep and i would need to
perform it perfectly out of fear that if
i didn't i wouldn't sleep and then that
would become a self-fulfilling prophecy
so for example i think i've brought this
up before when i talked about needing to
pee at night and i'd be laying in bed
and i'd be constantly thinking do i need
to pee is that the feeling of needing to
pee oh if i don't go pee now then i'm
gonna wake up in an hour and i'm gonna
have to pee then so i better get up now
and pee and then basically i would
physically make myself feel the
sensation of needing to pee even if
there wasn't like i don't know pee in
there whatever you want to call it so i
know this about myself i know what my
mind is capable of and i knew i knew
that the hunger that i was feeling at
night wasn't like an actual
physiological need for more calories it
wasn't that i was lacking in calories
and that you know i was starving all day
and then feeling the need to overeat at
night which happens a lot especially in
kind of disordered eating circles that
wasn't what was happening here and i
know this for various reasons but one of
which being that the hunger that i was
feeling when i was laying in my bed at
night would be gone the second that my
kids would call for me in the morning
and it'd be time to get out of bed that
feeling would be gone i wouldn't be
hungry anymore and actually i would
actually feel very full i would be
feeling very full from all the food that
i had just eaten in the night so i know
this about myself and i know that this
is just another manifestation of my
anxiety so just like any other kind of
compulsion or
obsession i know that the best thing to
do is to really challenge those beliefs
to challenge those assumptions and those
obsessions and the need to act out a
specific ritual in a specific way like
going downstairs to getting another
snack to eat that is just reinforcing to
me that i need to get up in the middle
of the night to eat and my rational
brain knows that i don't so the really
difficult thing for me right now is
going to be trying to balance out how to
trust and honor my body while also not
giving in
to
some of the kind of anxious compulsions
that make me feel safe and make me feel
comfortable and honestly that's just
feeling like a lot
four to six days later so i went to go
get some blood work done today um you
know really just to rule out any kind of
abnormalities with the blood sugars just
because it is strange that i'm getting
so hungry in the middle of the night
like that but if i'm honest with myself
i think i know that the real issue is
just that i need to get my anxiety
better under control and
that might
mean
more medication in the future and more
than just my regular sleep medication my
my dave ego and my thc your cbd and my
melatonin and supplements and things
like that for sleep it might just not be
enough and that feels like i'm opening
up just like this whole
new
scary can of worms
you know i'm like i'm terrified of
becoming addicted because i know myself
i have a super addictive personality and
i feel like i can't just take drugs away
i always have to add more and like my
super duper anxiety like catastrophic
belief in my mind that i've been working
through in therapy for the past 10 years
is like kind of becoming like a michael
jackson situation that's what i'm scared
of but i'm scared of all sorts of things
i'm scared of feeling unlike myself i'm
scared of
having to spend like a year plus trying
out all these different drugs and
experiencing all these horrible side
effects in the meantime especially
because a lot of ssris cause bloating
and digestive issues and constipation
which would exacerbate my sibo and my
ibs and all of the horrible gi troubles
i've had over the past i don't know 10
years then on the flip side i also know
that my sibo and my digestive issues are
also exacerbated by my anxiety so
yeah like this is this complicated black
hole cycle
this is a very obviously quite
complicated and
just
this is a very complicated and dangerous
cycle and i'm just trying to find the
fastest and simplest way to break it i
don't know i don't know if that's
possible okay so i ordered this little
testing kit um from my doctor it's
essentially a genetic test it's just an
oral kind of saliva swab that tests some
specific genes that have implications
for how different pharmaceutical
anti-anxiety and antipsychotic and
antidepressants work in the body so the
concept is that it may help cut down on
the kind of exploration phase of trying
to figure out which drug and which
dosage works for the specific patient
because we know that like most people
spend months if not years trying to find
an antidepressant or an anti-anxiety
medication that actually works for them
in a dose that doesn't um cause all
sorts of different unwanted side effects
and obviously my goal here is to reduce
the side effects and also reduce the
time it takes to get uh to a good place
that's really my big fear right now and
they have some studies i was like
reading up on it online um in like their
physician brochure and i think those
studies are probably uh funded by the
company themselves doesn't render them
useless and i think most of them looks
like they have to do more with kind of
subjective measures of success however i
love data i figured it's worth a go it's
a couple hundred dollars to do and it
doesn't hurt me to have this information
so if it can help me find a solution
that is going to help me feel better
faster
i'm all for it now i just have to read
the instructions because i always f
these things up
sashi's a very solid pressure so here i
am i got a canker square in there oh
this is really sexy like right in here i
look like a chipmunk
has aveeno in it
okay these are gotta be drenched at this
point
just a little more for good measure
okay
okay so a few
wii updates
um i had a call with my psychiatrist my
psychologist one of my best friends who
was also a psychiatrist and i got my
test results back so
we have a lot to unpack but first of all
i told my friend about the strange night
eating episode situation and she was
like um
abby like maybe your thc is giving you
the munchies and i was
like what
like
i i guess i like blocked out that common
side effect of thc from high school
but after she said that i was like
you're probably right okay i'm gonna try
to cut that out of my sleep cocktail and
just like see how i do and lo and behold
it's been like five nights and i have
not felt that strange overwhelming
ravenous hunger in the middle of the
night was it the drug was it the anxiety
honestly i know myself it was probably
the anxiety to be honest but i was
chatting with my psychologist about this
and we've come to the conclusion that i
often just need some kind of like
realistic scientific explanation for any
kind of experience or phenomenon in my
life um and that way i can just kind of
like put that to bed and be like yup
that's why that happened but it's not
happening now because of this and i can
just move on so even if i like half
believe that the thc did this to me and
now the thc is gone the anxiety over
feeling that hunger is also gone so yeah
like so far so good and i'm just kind of
gonna hope that that piece is behind me
now onto the drugs so before we got back
the genetics test everyone was in
agreement that um ciprolex or lexapro
same thing different name was likely the
best option for me which is also what i
was kind of hoping for too because it
does have one of the best side effect
profiles for most people so my
psychiatrist prescribed that and i spent
basically all week kind of hyping myself
up to start today and i was finally
feeling at ease and like somewhat
prepared and kind of excited about it
although of course i was still scared
but then over the weekend i got my
genetics test back and of course it
basically said that all of the ssris
including this one lexapro had a higher
side effect risk for me specifically so
like they could still be used
theoretically but they said to use with
caution and like i said earlier like the
test is not perfect so a lot of people
will be on a drug that seems to be
working for them but then the test
result will say it's not good for them
and vice versa um so it's not that this
wouldn't work for me or this would make
me you know have terrible side effects
necessarily but i just really wanted to
go into this with as much confidence as
possible to give it a fair shot and i
know how powerful my brain is and if i
go into this worrying that it's not
going to work it's going to make me
worse it's going to you know make me
more anxious it's going to give me
insomnia it's going to
make my bloating worse and my ibs worse
etc etc etc those things will probably
happen because my mind is so powerful it
can manifest these things physically as
well so like naturally i was so upset
all weekend long i really just don't
know where that even leaves me like what
what are my options at this point and i
have a call on tuesday with my
psychiatrist to really regroup but
like i just feel so
so discouraged and i don't know unless
she has some kind of like miraculous
idea but i'm at the point now where i
guess i just kind of feel like there is
not gonna be a perfect drug for me and
i'm gonna have to kind of experience
some kind of struggle to get through
this and to get better so i'll wait to
see what she says you know my husband
and i talked a lot over the weekend and
he's being so patient and kind and he's
really kind of encouraging me to
maybe try to change some things in my
life for the next couple weeks before i
hop into the medication
i'm not sure that there's a point in
that i'm not sure that like changing my
work schedule or him kind of like
helping out a little bit extra on
certain days or on the weekend is really
gonna change my brain it might make me a
little bit happier but at the end of the
day i don't think my anxiety is caused
by my unhappiness my anxiety probably
causes my unhappiness if that makes
sense but anyways it's another journey
another one for the books so um
i just hopped on another call with my
psychiatrist and
long story short we kind of like went
through the list of
the drugs on
the genetic test that i took
and you know she feels strongly just
based on her experience that a lot of
people will test as
saying there's they're going to have
side effects on a particular drug and
they've been taking that drug and it's
been totally fine so she still believes
that the um the lexapro like ciprolex is
the best option for me um but we went
through like every other option and most
of them that have you know decent side
effect profiles from her experience are
likely going to be too stimulating for
me um a lot of them are kind of good for
like pain or for concentration and
things like that but i don't need that
and i don't need stimulating it's going
to be a problem for me because it's
going to be a sleep issue
it's going to make me more kind of
nervous in the day i need to be like
sedated a little bit
so i am limited for options the one she
recommended um
and you know she liaised with a
colleague who also recommended effexor
but i've heard scary stories about
effexor and you know
the main one is that it's very very hard
to get off and i already have like such
an addictive personality that like this
just the idea of having to come off
something like that that's gonna cause
me
so much emotional and physical turmoil
like it's so scary
this is like what i was scared of
basically being like tethered to
something for the rest of my life unable
to
feel
free from it in a time and place where
maybe i can just be doing what i gotta
do on my own without being medicated
my husband has been so supportive and he
is trying to do all these little things
to help me and to make me feel better
so that maybe i can just like be happy
and not need medication
but i know myself i know my mind and i
know i can't just i can't just
live a normal life
my brain just doesn't have these
thoughts it's not like i'm working too
much and that stress is putting too much
strain on me and that's what's giving me
anxiety no if i were to quit my job and
be a stay-at-home mom or with 10 nannies
i would still find something to be
stressed about i would still find
something to keep me up at night
so even if he were to take me away to
live in the south of spain with no
responsibilities i would still not sleep
at night i would find something to be
anxious about it's a problem with my
brain and so i feel strongly that i i do
need to do this for myself even though
i'm so scared
so i'm probably going to end up going
with the siprelax the lexapro
even though i'm scared to have a
document standing staring in front of me
that says i'm probably going to react
poorly to it i'm just going to hope for
the best so that's all that i can do
so guys
wish me luck this is just so hard the
anxiety over anxiety over anxiety just
like the sandwich of anxiety i have
over every step of this is
paralyzing wow that was a lot okay
update i ended up getting a second
psychiatrist opinion um and we decided
to avoid the ssris based on my genetic
findings and instead try a non-ssri
uh drug called velazodone which is
actually an antidepressant but they are
apparently seeing some good results for
anxiety as like an off-label option and
if you google the lazadone the first
thing you'll see are the main side
effects which are nausea diarrhea and
ironically insomnia and they're usually
short-lived um and even though i started
like a super low dose like half the
normal starting dose just to kind of
like ease my way in i'm getting all
those things and i know you guys are
gonna probably ask me have you gained
weight is that one of your side effects
it's only been
like a week and a half so i don't think
i've gained any weight i will say i feel
a little more hungry than usual like
between meals um
like i have a bigger appetite than usual
which might actually be a good thing
because i have found that since getting
covered um you know a couple months ago
my appetite is
lower than normal and then basically
just out of an act of self-care i am
feeding myself even though i may not
have the best appetite to do so so i
might gain weight in this experience
which i know for a lot of people is very
scary
um but for me i just kind of have had to
accept that that may be just kind of
part and parcel with
getting better and getting to a better
mental state but i know that this is
going to be a journey like it's a
process so not unlike when i went
through ivf i
know that this is not a quick fix like i
just have to put my head down and expect
that the process may be long maybe windy
it might be messy but the end result
will hopefully be all worth it so i'm
still taking the day vigo and my
melatonin for sleep which is probably
kind of like helping to buffer some of
the trouble sleeping side effects of the
villazodome and our long-term plan is to
get me to like my happy dose on the
velazodone and then to transition from
my day vigo which is my sleep aid to
something called tresidone which is
apparently like a less addictive um
sleep option and then because that one
is a little easier to wean off of i will
slowly try to wean myself off of that
when i feel like i'm at a good place
with my anxiety so that's the long-term
plan
and
i feel
hopeful
like usually i feel like a complete
failure about my anxiety and my insomnia
and it's embarrassing i feel
less than i feel like why can't i just
get a grip um but for the first time in
a really long time i feel like i have a
plan and
i feel like i can
see
the light at the end of the tunnel
and that it's actually not that far away
so if you guys want to see a little
update on how things net out with you
know side effects and my final dose and
how i'm feeling and what other things we
need to throw in the mix
leave me a comment below if you are not
already subscribed hit that subscribe
button like this video if you want more
real vlogs from me and of course i will
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you